big news that came out of the Kurt
cousins conference call related to his
effort to discuss to analyze to assess
the possibility of playing games without
fans present which is a distinct
possibility in 2020 here's what Kirk
Cousins had to say honestly to go out
and just play the game would kind of be
refreshing and breath of fresh air to
just know that you know we don't have to
have all the smoke in the fire we can
just go play football so as long as
we're playing the game I won't have a
lot of complaints and hopefully if it's
still not return to normal hopefully we
can find a way to make it work
that's one of those moments where your
inner monologue and your outer monologue
should maybe not mesh because it just
doesn't sound good for a guy who makes
his money in large part based upon the
fans who pay to show up and watch him
play to create the impression not that
he just wouldn't mind if the fans aren't
there but he'd actually kind of prefer
it thank you I think this is Kirk
Cousins saying like could you imagine me
in prime time not having to deal with
the pressure of fans this could be my
first time I went a Monday night
football game I'm just shocked that that
sound clip exists of you saying that the
gap between patch Pro homes and Kirk
Cousins isn't that large that is was
that one Pat mahomes was injured when he
yes yes yes it was when he first came
back it was when he first came back and
cousins was on a tear then he was on a
ridiculous statistical tear at the time
which seems hard to believe in hindsight
but it was true at the moment and
mahomes was working his way back from
the from the knee injury that caused him
to miss a couple of games so yes thank
you for pointing out the context that
was not a January take that was a
November take it is interesting though
the Kirk Cousins is has this you know
perspective I think I think would happen
here more than anything is he's hearing
people say it would be great to get back
to normal it would be great to have
sports back in our lives and then he
took that message and pushed it to the
next level of it would almost be great
if fans never played or never were at
the stadium and never booed me and I
didn't have to have the pressure of
performing under you know thousands of
thousands of eyes
and let all of them down it'd be it'd be
great if they just stayed at home and we
had that wall that TV that was in
between us so I don't even have to think
about the hopes and dreams of Vikings
nations getting crushed and here's the
thing if you're an offensive player it
is better to not have fans there at all
games because for half the games you
don't have to worry about silent counts
you don't have to worry about crowd
noise George Kittel was on with his on
Friday and he explained I kind of like
it because I want to go to New Orleans
and Seattle and not have to worry about
not being able to hear myself think and
it's only a problem for your defense at
home games and that would be a major
disadvantage for the Vikings defense
because the noise at home games helps
them gain an edge over the offense which
loses its split second head start on the
play when you can't hear the snap count
when you don't know it's coming you lose
as an offense that little bit of a head
start that allows you to get in position
to block the pass rushers you're trying
to get around the edge it's a little
subtlety like that and it goes away
completely when you're on the road
trying to run your offense in a building
that's loud and the Vikings building is
one of the loudest so yeah it's gonna be
good for cousins because they do go to
Seattle and New Orleans this year to run
his offense without fans there but it's
going to be in eighth home games all of
a sudden not the advantage the Vikings
had because their defense isn't gonna
have that edge at the snap big cat
so my answer me this like trying to
think about the world without fans and
how this is actually gonna work would
the teams potentially still play in
their stadiums their empty stadiums or
would teams play in practice facilities
maybe not because those aren't big
enough like how would it work how would
teams you know execute this because I
think the one thing that would be really
weird is everyone kind of playing in a
dome situation where everyone has that
practice bubble and having really
controlled environment where now we
don't even know what's gonna happen
with the entire season where everyone is
playing indoors no fans like talk about
offensive numbers it will be insane well
and and I think that you raise a good
point that is still to be determined
because consider this it's one thing to
say
no fans in the any games right but what
if in California there's another spike
the second wave the third wave which
which has been much publicized and it
was the third wave of the Spanish flu in
1918 that killed more people than either
of the first two waves so what if we get
back to a point where there's a
stay-at-home order in California and
there's no exemption for sports well at
that point the 49ers can't play in their
stadium the Chargers and the Rams can't
play in their stadiums what the hell do
they do and and that's when you really
get into some strange outcomes where you
find an practice facility at a neutral
site and you play the game there you put
all the teams in one state Florida's
made it clear that sports are an
essential business do you have all 32
teams in Florida the way baseball is
talking about putting all 30 franchises
in Arizona and playing the games there
so these are all things to be determined
and these are all part of a plan that I
think the NFL needs to be working
through every permutation now so when
the virus dictates what is going to
happen it's just a matter of pressing
the button on the predetermined plan and
this is what we do if this happens and
if something else else happens this is
what we do instead of making it up on
the fly that's my big fear big cap that
the league is gonna find itself making
it up on the fly instead of identifying
every possible scenario and
brainstorming every possible solution
which is what they should be doing right
now and I fear that they're not
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports